alors voilà c'est bien
à casser là pour votre petit café
françois curiel et fini ça va tout le
monde devient très bien alors ce stage
je suis ravi d'être là sont normalement
ça me fait plaisir parce que là cette
année c'est moi qui remplace jean mi le
robot vous savez nous a quittés il nous
a quittés il rejoint sa planète la
décharge publique alors voilà je suis
ravie je suis le nouveau stagiaire de
salut les terriens thierry m'a appelé il
ya deux semaines je vous explique
comment ça s'est passé il m'a dit tom
est ce que ça te dirait de faire de la
télé j'ai dit va avec plaisir mais moi
je prends pas de drogue
il m'a dit t'inquiète pas je trouverai
un autre moyen pour payer vous avez vu
d'ailleurs cette semaine ce qui s'est
passé les employés d'air france à qui il
était en colère du coup ils ont mis le
drh à poil ouais [ __ ] avec les bruits
de couloirs de fond de tensions ou
thierry et soit vous êtes naturiste
alors ce soir on a un magnifique plateau
c'est incroyable ce soir c'est bien il
ya du poids retraite ça c'est sûr c'est
impressionnant c'est vrai non ce qui est
très bien c'est que tout le monde est
resté jeune ça c'est incroyable michel
drucker il est resté jeune grâce au vélo
jean michel jarre il est resté jeune
grâce au voyage enrico macias grâce à la
musique et thierry ardisson grâce à sa
maquilleuse
françois damiens je l'aide vraiment et
sincèrement j'aime beaucoup vous êtes
fait connaître grâce à vos caméras
cachées alors malheureusement vous
pouvez plus en faire aujourd'hui parce
que les gens vous reconnaissent vous
avez exactement le même problème que
benjamin castaldi lui aussi peut plus
faire de télé parce que les gens le
reconnaissent
je sois qui rit on reçoit laurent ournac
laurent ournac c'est l'homme qui a
prouvé à tf1 pour pouvait perdre du
poids sans participer à koh lanta
noizet on va en parler deux secondes
c'est quand même extraordinaire ce qui
s'est passé vous avez perdu 50 kg enfin
perdu en fait vous il vous en retirez un
morceau de l'estomac donc la formule
exacte c'est pas j'ai perdu 50 kg mais
j'évite danger 50 kg
[Musique]
maintenant mesdames et messieurs je suis
ici pour vous poser les questions trop
con que thierry n'a pas voulu vous posez
on va commencer avec isabelle mergault
isabelle ou jouez votre pièce avec
sylvie vartan au théâtre des variétés
qui à deux pas du musée grévin c'est
pour que sylvie vartan puisse rentrer
plus vite chez elle
natacha polony alors on attache à vous
aviez déjà atteint votre taille adulte à
l'âge de 12 ans vous avez d'autres
points communs avec mimie mathy ou pas
alors valérie pécresse vous avez aucune
casserole aucune mise en examen et aucun
dérapage à votre actif qu'est ce que
vous foutez chez les républicains
jean luc mélenchon jean luc lors des
dernières élections présidentielles vous
avez terminé derrière marine le pen
c'était quoi le pire c'était là la
défaite ou la vue
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu